A woman is now admitting that she was paid
to lie, that Dr. Anthony Foushee sexually
assaulted her.
This is the same woman who lied that Robert
Mueller had sexually assaulted her.
It appears that exactly the same people put
her up to it.
Now, this story is crazy, but I actually think
the context is what's most disturbing and
outrageous.
And I can explain that in a moment.
But first, the details.
A woman named Diana Rodriguez claimed that
Dr. Anthony Fauci, the country's lead infectious
disease expert, he's been on Trump's White
House Corona Virus task force.
He used to be a fixture at the press briefings.
He testified before the Senate yesterday.
Diana Rodriguez claimed that Foushee sexually
assaulted her in 2014 to a reporter.
That reporter reason's Nancy Román had been
working on the story, looking at the allegations
from Diana Rodriguez.
We've since learned that Diana Rodriguez is
really Diana on dry day, and she is actually
connected to Jacob Wall, a pro-Trump troll
who previously tried to orchestrate completely
bogus sexual assault allegations against Robert
Mueller during the time when Robert Mueller
was doing the Trump Russia investigation.
So once again, you've got the same people
getting caught trying to do the same thing,
trying to frame a public figure that was inconvenient,
I guess, to the right with sexual assault.
Diana Underwritings said she was paid to come
forward with the bogus allegations.
So those are the simple details.
But I believe that the surrounding elements
are actually what's more important here.
Why is anybody trying to frame an infectious
disease doctor at all?
Why is Rand Paul, as I will soon show you,
going after Dr. Foushee?
This is actually the story.
A doctor who simply doing his job has done
it for Republican presidents and four Democratic
presidents is trying to save lives.
Whose ideology he says his health and is nearly
80 years old.
Right.
I mean, this guy's been doing this for decade
after decade.
This diminutive 79 year old doctor has become
the enemy of the Trump ist, right.
Why is he an enemy?
Because he things he he says things which
are based in science and medicine, which sometimes
conflict with the completely fake, phony narrative
that Donald Trump concocts and creates.
Whether it's about fact-checking, about hydroxy
chloroquine, whether it's about a second wave,
whether it's about vaccinations, whether it's
about reopening, whatever it is he has been
seen.
Dr. Foushee, by the Trump is right as an antagonist
of Donald Trump, when really he is and I guess
we would call it an agonist for the truth.
And what makes him invariably an enemy of
the Trump is right is that he appears to interfere
with Donald Trump's lies.
Imagine doing your job so well, being way
more trusted by the public than Trump.
Polls show conclusively the public by large
margins trusts Anthony Foushee on an coronavirus
way
more than they trust Donald Trump.
And the reaction from some is this guy's the
enemy fire foushee.
And let's get somebody to lie and claim Dr.
Foushee sexually assaulted them.
So Jacob Wall and his partner Burkeman are,
of course, a huge part of the problem.
But the hostility among the Trump is outright
hostility to science.
Hostility to reason and to medicine and to
doctors and to public health.
That is really the big story here.
Now, the second part of this is why aren't
Jacob Wallan Burkeman in prison?
They tried to frame Robert Mueller and now
they tried to frame Anthony Foushee.
Is it because the law doesn't matter anymore
at minimum in civil court?
You could see lawsuits certainly over the
Robert Mueller allegations.
And in reality, it's not outrageous to think
that there could be criminal charges here.
And once again, our country is an embarrassment,
truly.
They're laughing at us all over the world
Germany, Spain, Italy, France, South Korea,
Taiwan.
They take the virus seriously.
They revere their medical experts.
They do what they're supposed to do.
They deal with the virus.
And now they can start to reopen to different
degrees in different countries depending on
what's going on.
Meanwhile, here in the United States, people
demand that Dr. Foushee be fired, ignored,
and that Donald Trump be listened to.
And now the idea of framing Dr. Foushee with
false sexual assault allegations is uncovered.
You know, I got e-mails yesterday about our
story.
The world is is laughing at Trump and it's
really bad for us.
And there were people, a lot of people from
Europe and other countries
said, you know, David, we were laughing.
We're not laughing anymore.
Now we just feel really bad for you guys.
But we also are worried for ourselves because
we're used to the US as a productive partner
in solving problems.
To the extent that we've been able to solve
problems in the past and the U.S., isn't that
any.
So there's laughter happening, but there's
also significant concern that we are just
so backwards on every single one of these
elements